Ang quantum computing ay para sa mga problemang hindi kayang
harapin ng mga klasikal na computer —
tulad ng paghahanap ng tamang materyales para makapagbigay-daan
sa carbon capture para talagang
labanan ang climate change, para matugunan ang
mas mahusay na mga pataba na
hindi nakakasama sa kalikasan pero nagpapanatili rin ng
supply chain ng pagkain na kailangan para mabuhay ang mundo.
Mayroon ding mga pundamental na tanong tungkol sa kung paano nagtutugma ang ating uniberso
at kung paano kumikilos ang bagay sa antas ng atomo
at subatomo na kailangan nating malaman —
ito ang susunod na hangganan.
Tingnan natin ang isang larangan na kasalukuyang pinagtatrabahuhan:
ang paghahanap ng mga bagong baterya.
Binago ng mga baterya ang ating buhay sa pamamagitan ng pagbibigay-daan sa atin na magdala ng
mga computer at smartphone.
Pero may higit pang magagawa — napakahalaga ng mga baterya
para sa ating malinis na kinabukasan ng enerhiya,
maging sa pagpapatakbo ng mga electric na sasakyan o talagang
pagsusulong ng renewable energy.
Kailangan natin ng pundamental na ibang kimika
para lumikha ng mga baterya
para bukas. Ang quantum computing
ay magbibigay-daan sa atin na epektibong tumingin sa loob ng baterya
habang nagaganap ang napaka-kumplikadong mga reaksyon nito, para mapagisipan natin
ang mga bagong materyales
at ang istraktura ng mga bateryang kakailanganin
para patakbuhin ang susunod na henerasyong mga device.
Paano tayo makakarating doon? Sa pamamagitan ng pagbuo ng pinaka-advanced na quantum
na mga device at isang development platform
at ginagawa itong accessible sa buong mundo.
Sa pamamagitan lamang ng pagtutulungan ngayon
magagawa nating malutas ang mga problemang haharapin natin
nang magkasama sa hinaharap.